one of the scariest moments of my career
started on a dark october morning in
2018.
i'm a professional athlete and my
training schedule can be a lot six days
a week five hours a day it's intense
still i never trained that early
but on this day a special type of fear
brought me out at 4 am before the sun
a fear that someone might discover a
secret i'd been keeping
i was six months pregnant
i was pregnant and i was scared enough
to train in the dark so that no one
would see the life that was growing
inside of me i feared that if a fan or
someone posted a photo
that my sponsor would immediately change
their mind about wanting to work with me
i feared that i would be forced to
choose between motherhood and being a
competitive athlete
i feared that the career i worked so
hard to build
would disappear
just like that
you think i'm exaggerating right
how could a six-time olympic champion a
16-time world champion a world record
holder possibly think that her career
might be over by doing something as
natural as having a baby
well i'm not exaggerating
getting pregnant in track and field has
been called the kiss of death
and it comes with a lot of fear just
like for women in many professions
i have been watching women that i
respect and teammates of mine high
pregnancies since i was 19 years old
i've seen women have to make
gut-wrenching decisions
like deciding whether to recover their
health or return to the sport
deciding whether to stay in the hospital
with a sick child
or go to a race so that they don't
receive a further pay reduction
i know what some of you might be
thinking
we all choose to get pregnant right
if a sponsor doesn't want to pay an
athlete who's not out on the track
winning that's just part of the deal
right
well
i think the deal's rigged
i think that companies want to have it
both ways
and i think it's time we change
sports companies love to tell women that
they can have it all they can do it all
they can be it all we've all seen those
inspirational ads
i remember meeting with nike leadership
in 2010 and they told me about an
initiative they sponsored called the
girl effect
they promoted adolescent girls as the
key to improving societies around the
globe
they said they believed in women and
girls and if i joined nike i could
empower them and i believe that
but guess what
girls come from somewhere
and women having babies during
childbearing years is something that
should be celebrated not punished it
should be a part of a normal thriving
professional athletic career and women
in all fields should never feel the need
to hide a pregnancy
at 4am
in the dark so that they won't be
photographed doing that thing that they
love
thank you
remember how scared i told you i was
when i was on the track that day
my mind was racing with the consequences
of my decision to start a family
i had already been going through a
difficult renegotiation period with nike
and they were already offering me 70
less than what i had previously been
making and that was even before they
knew about the baby
don't even get me started with the
ageism that is embedded in the
capitalist dream
so
when i told them about my pregnancy i
asked for a clause in the contract that
specified they wouldn't reduce my pay
within 12 months of giving birth
they said yes
but you knew there was going to be a but
right
but
it was only a yes for me
they weren't ready to offer that same
protection for all female athletes they
weren't ready to set the precedent
a couple days later my agent called me
nike wanted to use me in a commercial
for the women's world cup
i couldn't believe it nike wanted to use
me to tell women and girls that they
could do anything even though the
contract before me said the exact
opposite
i knew what i had to do
i knew i had to leave
i knew i was afraid
but i did it anyways
i wrote an op-ed in the new york times
calling out nike's maternity policy
and i wasn't the only one
my teammates and i we helped turn the
tide now nike offers 18 months maternity
protection and other sponsors
and other sponsors like ultra noon
brooks and burton they came forward and
they announced their new guarantees for
female athletes who start families while
being sponsored
too late for me but amazing for the
women coming up now
i didn't resign with nike and i'm here
to tell the tale but more than that i'm
here to tell you that you can do it too
once you find the courage to believe in
yourself your own worth your own values
it gets easier it's when you take a
stand that you start to understand how
to overcome that fear and how to make a
change for yourself
and sometimes for others
i went on to find a new sponsor in the
female-led female focus athleta and they
helped me challenge
and they helped me challenge the
international olympic committee's child
care policy together we raised two
hundred thousand dollars for female
athletes to be able to afford child care
when they go to races because women have
babies and these children don't
disappear when the races begin
i made it back to the olympics two years
after giving birth i won a gold and a
bronze and i
and i became the most decorated american
track and field athlete of all time
all
all while my daughter was watching
i was running for so much more than for
medals or for a time on the track
i was running as a representation for
women and for mothers and for anybody
who had been told that their story was
over
i remember crossing that line in tokyo
and having such a sense of fulfillment
i looked down at my feet
and for the first time in my entire
career i wasn't wearing adidas i wasn't
wearing nike i was wearing safe
the women's footwear brand that i
founded
designed for and by women when i was
left without a footwear sponsor because
i was tired of not being valued or able
to show up fully as myself
i learned that my voice has power and
when i bet on myself change is possible
during the pandemic we all saw what
happens when that thin line between our
professional and personal lives
permanently blurs we have seen women
step back give up drop out as having it
all became doing it all and doing it all
became impossible
we have got to stop forcing people to
choose between parenting and doing the
work that they love and we've got to
stop pretending that we're not making
those decisions because the results
affect us all not just women but men in
our children too by creating the
environment that we all live work love
and raise our families in
isn't it past time that we call out the
hypocrisy and create a new normal
one with real generosity humanity and
truth at the center
not some misplaced sense of what
business is or does
we should say what we will tolerate and
as we all recover from the pandemic that
has flattened us
let's just not rebuild the same version
of the broken system that we had before
but let's learn and create something new
each one of us has a role to play
and you don't have to be an olympian to
create change for yourself or for others
everyone in this room can bet on
themselves
it will typically happen in moments of
fear when you don't see the path forward
in my own experience it was a terrifying
decision
but that will be your first clue
that feeling of being terrified is your
invitation to create change
you have to acknowledge those feelings
you have to brave them and you have to
fight to move forward
it won't be easy
you will be afraid
your voice will shake but what i can
absolutely promise you
is that it will be worth it
thank you